there is a really really crazy Christian
trumpet named Rick Wiles we've covered
him before on the show some of the
things we've covered our Rick Wiles
saying that vegan burgers are a satanic
plot to destroy people's souls he has
said that Muslims have taken over
America hard to imagine aren't they like
0.6% of the population some kind of
numerology conspiracy proves that Barack
Obama is responsible for the death of
Supreme Court Justice Antonin Scalia he
previously said somebody's going to die
due to gay marriage
Rick wiles has said that Jews will use
red flag laws to take guns from
Christians and then kill them this is
truly a religious nut lunatic of the
highest order he is now saying actually
what we've all been predicting for a
long time if Donald Trump is removed
from office even through constitutional
legal proper means like impeachment
there will be violence this is a trump
estanque there will be violence from
trumpets if Trump is removed yeah Rick
we know take a look at the clip if they
take him out there's gonna be violence
in America that's all there is to it
yeah well we say right now however he
leaves there's going to be violence in
America and I believe there are people
in this country veterans they're Cowboys
mountain men I mean guys that know how
to fight okay and they're going to make
a decision that the people that did this
to Donald Trump are not going to get
away from with it and they're gonna hunt
them down
I'm serious they're gonna hunt them down
I don't want it to happen I don't want
to see country go this way but once hell
breaks loose if if these people in
Washington think that they're going to
get away with it it's not going to
happen
the Trump supporters are going to hunt
them down
veterans Cowboys
and mountain men who know how to fight
and they will be violent if Donald Trump
is removed look at the victimology
language the people who do this to
Donald Trump you mean hold them
accountable in accordance with the
Constitution right the people who do
this to Donald Trump will be hunted down
by trumpets with guns who might be
veterans or Cowboys or mountain men
this is sadly maybe the only time Rick
wiles has made a correct analysis of
something that I can think of he's right
I've said this and I will actually go
even further I believe that if Donald
Trump simply loses the 20/20 election
forget about impeachment forget about
the 25th amendment forget about any of
that stuff if Donald Trump loses the
20/20 re-election campaign and claims
that there was voter fraud or fake
voters or people voting illegally or
whatever which he will likely do I think
even in that case Trump is speaking
Donald Trump has successfully weaponized
ignorance in a way that no recent
president has done george w bush did it
to some degree but it was nothing
compared to what has been done right now
and one of the outcomes of that
weaponization of ignorance will be that
trump's followers will quickly turn to
violence in exactly the way Rick wiles
is saying they will this is an
unfortunate reality it's a reality of
the political and cultural status quo in
which we live which has been escalated
by Donald Trump's rhetoric the one
semi-good argument I've heard about gun
ownership is does the left really want
the violent right to have all the guns
we need to get guns to to defend
ourselves from the right now of course
in the real world would more guns really
solve the issue it's dubious reasoning
as we've exposed before but it is
reasoning that I often hear from pro-gun
owners a pro gun ownership leftists
which is the right is really violent and
they may get very much more violent if
Donald Trump loses or is removed don't
we need guns to protect ourselves don't
we need guns to protect ourselves let me
know what you think either by replying
to this YouTube clip or sending me a
tweet at D Pakman on Twitter how can the
question is how can
learned about violins are you either
around a trump defeat in 2020 around
removal via some other means whether
it's impeachment or the 25th amendment
or trump choosing to resign to avoid
impeachment or whatever scenario we are
talking about what is your sense of the
risk of violence that exists I've
actually had I guess I can say I've had
some conversations with individuals
associated with law enforcement about
this issue and it is not an unfamiliar
concern at least to the folks that I've
spoken to the potential real physical
violence that could happen if Donald
Trump I'm trying to figure out the right
way to say it does not remain president
beyond January of 2021 because it could
that could account for removal or simply
losing an election that he claims was
unfair let me know what you think I do
want to hear from you